hi there i'm gonna start my
podcast thing too steve kaufman here
again and um
i put up a
a video the other day so i'm kind of in
the mood so i'm going to do another one
here i i think sometimes i don't speak
loud enough so i'm going to try to speak
a little louder
uh it's a sunny day here in vancouver
it's a warm day uh this morning i was on
the ice with my son and grandson we
played hockey
uh mark of course who played
professional hockey for 10 years in
europe and japan and
played for team canada he was taking us
through a bunch of drills
and i was trying to keep up to my
grandson
i worked up a tremendous amount of sweat
and then i've been working here this
afternoon
editing my blog book
uh i've also been trying to start a blog
in russian because there's a chance that
i'll be running a regular blog in
russian about uh the winter olympics
here in vancouver it remains to be seen
if i can pull it off i'll obviously need
some help to correct my russian so
anyway that's kept me busy and then i
thought i would
i would do a little video here and talk
about
what it is that i find annoying about
some teachers
and it really hit home to me today
because of two reasons
first of all i
because i subscribed to google alert i
get alerted when there are articles
about language
so there was an article about
the intensive summer language programs
offered at ucla
i will put a link to that on my blog
the linguist on language blog
and
so i read the article and it talks about
their intensive summer program but most
of the article talks about
they see they have five days four days
they're in class and on the fifth day
they go out
and they have things like a scavenger
hunt
in russian bookstores and they go to a
tchaikovsky concert or they do all this
kind of thing
the other four days as it's described in
the article is spent on the things they
have to do like grammar and
pronunciation and so forth and i thought
to myself
you know if i
as a university student
am taking a course in russian
i don't want to be organized into a
scavenger hunt if i want to go to a
russian bookstore i'll go there on my
own i don't need to go
uh with a group
uh
and besides which i i want to go when i
want to go not because the teacher
decided on friday that we should all go
and have a scavenger hunt
but in the meantime the courses they
describe as being grammar and
pronunciation and others pretty
traditional stuff
um i came across this before there was
an esl program i was talking to someone
at carleton university in ottawa and
they had the students
doing uh slide shows
and i mean it was all koreans doing it
probably speaking korean to each other
there were about 10 words of english
used and they all had a lot of fun
pasting stuff into a slideshow using the
new technology using blogs and i don't
know what else
i mean i would never want to do that if
they try to organize me into joining up
and pasting and scavenging i mean like
forget it
uh you know even when i was at
university i mean you must be joking i'm
here to learn the language let's do
something interesting let's listen let's
read let's talk let's do something with
the language
uh
and i find there's a lot of this kind of
activity i remember when i was a little
kid i still remember i was in grade four
and we had art class so of course we
were actually allowed to draw what we
wanted so i drew a hockey player what
else am i going to draw so we had a
teacher who was from germany or
somewhere
she didn't realize that hockey players
wear short pants so she came up to me
and she said no no no
and she where i had drawn a hockey
player with short pants and then hockey
saw you know shin pads and whatnot she
drew it like ski pants
like straight line
because that's how you're supposed to
draw
pants
well
if i want to draw a hockey guy with
short pants
let me draw my hockey i still remember
it
i remember two once when uh my son
who is now professor of political
science at the university of london
mark's older brother he had an
assignment
and he was asked to compare this was
maybe he was 11 or 12 he was asked to do
a project an essay you know comparing
russia to china
he did a phenomenal job what he had to
say made a lot of sense he had
identified the differences resources in
one country uh industrial you know the
development of industry and the other he
had maps he had pictures
and he got three out of 25.
i mean he put so much work into that
thing it was tremendous very mature
teacher said you didn't ask answer the
specific question that i gave you
like who cares maybe your question was
stupid to begin with the fact is that
the student spent a lot of time
researching put a lot of work and wrote
a very good paper okay knock him down
three points out of 25 because he didn't
answer your question
so i always find that teachers they
either treat the students like children
or they want to tell them what to do and
i find that most often they get in the
way
rather than standing behind the student
encouraging them finding out what it is
they're interested in perhaps stimula
trying this trying that seeing what can
turn their crank
and of course the other thing is this
whole issue with this list serve
where i had said some teacher and most
of these people i have to say these
english teachers are
either extremely
pretentious in the way they write or
they make no sense whatsoever
or and and they're quite ignorant and
that's what i find i'm just appalled at
the quality of people they have on this
list serve i i just can't believe it at
any rate someone began by saying you
know the japanese have a more
teamwork approach
because of the american occupation which
is a completely stupid thing to say i
mean forget about confucianist influence
from china forget about their own
traditions at five years of american
occupation that's created their sense of
teamwork so i said no that's not the
case
and then they've been all coming back
they never admit they're wrong and uh
someone else was saying that you know
the japanese are all this top down and i
and i use the word that that
the activity of the ins this this sort
of insubordination
by what i call hot-headed japanese
officers
uh precipitator to help precipitate the
second world war now i wasn't there but
that's what i have read
so this person said no you can't put
that because hot-headed is is you know
we can't have that
uh it might offend people of japanese
ancestry so i went back to her and i
said
first of all this is not controversial i
could say this in japan and it would not
be controversial
second of all you're talking about
people of japanese ancestry
in the united states those people are
american they don't care what i call
japanese officers in the second world
war in japan
and she came back to me and she said
well you know
we have to be very considerate and we
can't use words that might be considered
inconsiderate and this could offend
against uwen could offend people uh who
may not and she said may not like their
officers being called hot-headed like
who's their officers these are japanese
americans americans of japanese ancestry
who might be teaching english and who
are on your list serve are going to be
offended because i called a japanese
officer hot-headed
i mean eisenhower
nimitz
schwarzkopf those are all
american uh
officers with german names would they be
offended or other
americans of german ancestry if i said
that the ss officers were not nice guys
would they be offended i don't think so
but what bugs me most of all is she went
on and on about how you know you must
understand that you know my job here is
to sit here and make sure that
we all treat each other with respect and
what do you mean these are adults if
adult teachers cannot get on a list
serve and cannot be allowed to talk to
each other
uh discussing things of importance
like why do they need a mother hen
sitting over to make sure that they are
all considerate to each other
a perhaps that's why there are only
clueless people on the list serve
because anybody serious is not going to
put up with this
anyway so you know i think if you're
going to be a teacher don't look down at
people don't teach them how to think
don't help them to become to
as one person put it i help them to
maturely discuss ethical questions don't
help them to be mature they're probably
more mature than you are
judging by the way you write on this
list sir
so yeah i'm a little bit annoyed
these are the kinds of activities that
are funded always funded you know every
little
little plot they can scheme to get some
money to do something silly where we
treat everybody like little children
they get money for they run it for a
while it doesn't really help anyone then
the money runs out and the thing is over
so yeah i think there is horrendous
waste in our public education system
and at that i'm gonna have to leave and
i might get back to that subject later
on they certainly don't pay any
attention to what we're doing but hey
such is life bye for now